vidéo parce qu'il n'a pas pu être
présent avec nous aujourd'hui sa vision
des enjeux de la présidence française de
l'union européenne puis nous aurons en
direct et en vidéo cette fois ci jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale clément bonne
chère françois scherr toutes et tous je
suis d'abord désolé de ne pas pouvoir
être physiquement parmi vous aujourd'hui
pour parler notamment d'europe car
j'accompagne ce samedi le premier
ministre a toulouse pour un débat sur
l'europe à l'occasion des conférences
régionales que nous organisons avec marc
fesneau notamment ce week-end encore
mais je tenais néanmoins à pouvoir vous
adresser quelques mots et a participé
malgré tout à votre université de
rentrée d'abord pour vous dire à quel
point je suis heureux comme ministre
chargé des affaires européennes de
pouvoir compter sur l'inspiration
l'engagement les idées du modem l'europe
est dans votre adn l'europe est notre
priorité depuis quatre ans mais pour le
modem pour le courant démocrate c'est
une tradition c'est une identité c'est
une inspiration je le disais chaque jour
très franchement et je sais à quel point
vous aurez à coeur de continuer à faire
vivre ses idées européennes dans un
moment politique qui sera si important
bien sûr les échéances que nous
connaissons où je crois l'europe jouera
encore un rôle car nous avons assumé
d'avoir l'europe conquérant savoir
l'europe ambitieuse de faire des
propositions de défendre notre projet
européen et nos idées pour l'europe tout
simplement d'être fiers que la france
soit forte en europe ce n'est pas un
affaiblissement de notre souveraineté
c'est un renforcement de notre capacité
d'action et de notre identité française
vous en être convaincu mais nous l'avons
je crois ensemble mise en oeuvre ces
dernières années nous devons le
revendiquer continuez en être fier
porter ce combat politique dans les mois
qui viennent tous ensemble et puis bien
sûr ce moment ce sera aussi la
présidence française de l'union
européenne au premier semestre 2022
beaucoup d'entre vous pensent notamment
à nos députés européens mais beaucoup
plus largement sont très engagées dans
la préparation de cette échéance il ne
faut pas la voir comme un risque comme
un moment à contourner à éviter je crois
au contraire qu'il faut pleinement
l'assumer le ferons là aussi ensemble
car une présidence de l'union européenne
cela revient presque tous les 15 ans la
dernière avait lieu en 2008 la prochaine
est prévue pour 2035 alors utilisons ce
moment pour faire vivre l'europe en
france pour faire avancer les idées de
la france en europe pour que l'europe
parle encore davantage français dans
tous les sens du terme et que ensemble
nous vous démocrates européens engagés
nous soyons au rendez-vous pour
revendiquer un bilan pour faire avancer
des sujets pour projeter aussi l'europe
sur les grands défis du moment je sais
qu'ils tiennent à coeur en particulier à
françois bayroux la question de la dette
la question de la démographie la
question des grandes transitions
climatique et numérique l'europe ne peut
pas être absente de ces grands
bouleversements internationaux où les
subir nous sommes fiers nous sommes
engagés nous sommes déterminés à être
des européens actifs pas des européens
bea comme peu caricaturée ceux qui
croient à la cause européenne mais les
européens du quotidien du concret des
résultats et de la fierté pour tout cela
merci beaucoup merci encore pour
l'université de rentrée qui nous
apportera je crois encore d'autres idées
pardon à nouveau de ne pas être
directement parmi vous mais j'ai une
pensée pour vous tout pour vous tous
aujourd'hui et j'espère j'en suis sûr à
très bientôt merci